In this week's lecture, we're going to be looking at the advantages...
...and disadvantages of the jury system.
A jury is a group of usually 12 ordinary people...
...who have been selected to listen to the facts in a trial in a law court...
...and decide on whether the case has been proved.
It's claimed that the advantage of the jury system...
...is that it ensures a fair trial, especially in criminal cases.
People who are accused of an offence are tried by their peers, the general public,...
...rather than trained lawyers, who used their common sense to reach a verdict...
...based solely on the evidence they have heard in the case.
However, in recent years many lawyers have argued...
...that the disadvantage of the jury system is that in some cases, such as serious fraud,...
...the facts are generally too complex for the ordinary person in the street to follow.